[موسيقى]
حاليا هم الناس الحاسيين بقيمه الرسائل
المكتوبه
في زمن حاليا العولمه بقت طاغيه على
المجتمع
واغلب التواصل بقى بالانترنت فجاتنا
الرساله وديناها للدكتور حقيقي الاحساس
بتاع الفرح الدخل في الدكتور احنا كنا
حاسينه
[موسيقى]
مصطفى محمد نور الماحي فزع
وفزع ما لقبت فزع هو اسم العائله
المهنه السابقه اوبريشن في شركه الصابر
المهنه الحاليه
سوشيال ميديا ماركتين وكنت
قصه البريد نفسها
لكن
اندثرت ما قلته
او اندثرت حاليا في العصر الحديث لكن نحن
رجعناها في 2017 ممكن تقول لي بيحل بيحله
جديده وبيفهم جديد ما بعيد من الرسائل
القديمه لكن هي مستحدثه شويه
الفكره في اخر سنه في الجامعه
الموضوع كان هو ممكن تقولي فكره جات ما
بين
الفكره بتاعت موقع صراح اللي هو كان بيبعت
رسائل
وكان بين الشركات الحدائق للناس فقلت انا
ليه ما اعمل فكره
تجمع بين الحاجتين دول اللي هو
حاجه مقروءه وفي نفس الوقت ممكن تدخل
السرور في نفس الانسان
حاليا هم الناس الحاسيين بقيمه الرسائل
المكتوبه في زمن حاليا العولمه بقت طاغيه
على المجتمع
واغلب التواصل بقى بالانترنت تزول لو كتب
لك رساله موجهه لك في شخصك انت بتحس
النزول لا قدرك فما بالك انه جاتك رساله
مكتوبه بخط اليد فالزول دائما بحس
بالتقليديه والجمال في الحاجه القديمه
والحاجه بتحسن
والمبادره بدات من جامعه السودان الهندسه
انتشرت لكل السودان وبقينا شغالين
بستايل ما هو ما يستايل توظيفي بقدري مع
انه نحن هو مساعده الشباب اللي عندهم
موهبه في الكتاب وفي الرسم وفي سعاده
الناس اصلا عشان نقدر اول حاجه مبدئيا
نكبر القاعده حقتنا ويقدروا يقولون مصدر
دخل اضافي في حياته فكل ولايه من ولاده
السودان حاليا بقى فيها مكتب
وكل جامعه فيها مكتب متخصص لسعيد عندنا
مكتب خارج السودان في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
ممكن نستقبل منه رسائل من الخارج او نرسل
له رسائل ان شاء الله في القريب العاجل
يكون عندنا مكاتب في الدول العربيه كلها
ان شاء الله
موضوع انه المباد تكون مبادئه ربحيه ما
كاد الغرض منها ربح زين اصلا غرضنا في
الاول وفي الاخير سعادة لكن لقينا مع ظروف
الحياه الناس بقت محتاجه انها يكون عندها
دخل حتى لو كان بسيط لكن نحن ما بنلعب على
الدخل بصوره كبيره بنلعب على الفاليو بتاع
الاسعاف بتاع الناس والقيمه الاولى بعد
ذلك لو جاتنا
من اجمل الرسائل اللي جاتنا في سعر البريد
كاتبه طالب لاستاذ الخرطوم
وكان العلاقه بيناتهم قويه جدا
الدكتور كان كفيف
انت كانت من اصعب الحاجات الواجهات كيف
نكتب رساله
لكن الطالب كان اذكى مننا
وكتب الرساله باللغه
الحاجه جدا قبل ما تسعدني المرسل اليه
فجاتنا الرساله
وديناها للدكتور حقيقي الاحساس بتاع الفرح
الدخل في الدكتور احنا كنا حاسينه لانه
تقييمك للانسان بيوريك مدى اجتهادك معاه
في ايصال السعاده انت بتوصل اليه بدينا
بعتبر الرساله لخالده بن سعيد
في 2018 رجعت الخرطوم
من اجمل الرسائل اللي كان احنا وصلنا لها
[موسيقى]